just around the trade deadline at
nationals park chris bryant on the phone
we think uh getting the news that he had
been traded to the san francisco giants
an emotional moment in the dugout
pregame with anthony ioposi
javi baez and anthony rizzo also moving
on to new teams
last start july 25th at baltimore
received the no decision three runs
on five hits over five any struck out
six walk one remember he gave up three
solo home runs and left with the lead
big slow hook
72 trace pereira stays with it and
that's how the home stand gets underway
oh there's the heater
palo espino
after the 71 curve
that 90 played a lot faster
and him out ahead
luis garcia out in right field and paulo
espino gets this one off to a great
start jake out there tonight with a five
and nine record a 6.30 era it's been a
really rough go for him
of late and he's coming off that
strained hamstring trevor williams was
supposed to be the starter tonight but
he's been dealt to the new york mets
sink or slider curve and change for the
veteran right-hander
stevenson and grab by alcantara nice
play at short one down
it's been a while
broken bat
knocked down by wisdom at first and
he'll make the tag escobar retire two
outs
washington eight games below 500 right
now ron as you say that here's the
bouncer to the right side in shallow
right bodhi gloves it and throws to
wisdom and it's a one two three inning
for jake arrieta one out and luis garcia
will be the batter
swinging a drive and a year to deep
right center back goes hayward again
looking up this may go and it is gone
goodbye
bang zoom goes luis garcia with a home
run over the big wall in right center
field he has his first home run of the
big leagues this year in the third of
his career and it's the nationals one
and the cubs nothing welcome to the
future
[Applause]
this will drop into right center
parlor makes the turn heads for third
ortega hits the cutoff man
and carter kibum
is two for his last three
ariana ready for the o2 now to paolo
espino swing minimus and that's going to
end the inning
good swing
headed towards the gap out in right
center and sergio stand up double to get
things started in the top of the third
nobody out one and two now bell the only
guy shallow and the swing and miss
here's ortega the center fielder
jacks that one extra bases and a run
will score alcantara coming home
ortega thinking about third and he will
hold at second base the rbi double
and this one lined
to happ who cuts it off stevenson good
jump out of the box
thinking
all the way here's how cd's escobar
escobar had a broken back ground out to
first the one one from ariat escobar
drops above third base out it's a beauty
arietta bear hand has to hurry the throw
to first is off the glove of the second
baseman bodhi trickling into right field
so stevenson will score and the
nationals take the lead two to one
swinging a high high drive to left field
para drifting back now moving in a bit
calling for it
and this one finally comes down in his
glove a mile high pop up for wisdom the
one-two pitch there will be no grand
slam here he takes a curved strike three
call
bodies over two take that
boy in the dirt hitters be funnel timing
way off right now
so second and third two down for andrew
stevenson
got him
and contreras will clean it up
and we'll keep an eye on there
bullpen here's a swing and a high fly
ball straight away center stevenson in
his tracks there
the 01 to schwendel is popped up shallow
center escobar and garcia it'll be the
second baseman garcia calling for it and
he makes the catch
had him all locked up
matt duffy at third
one down and delivers the pitch
a breaking ball called strike three as
that one floated right back into the
zone there's josh bell right-handed
where he has plenty of power
oh my
deep into the night
see
you
later
over the bullpen 3-1 nets
on bells
17 and number six from the right side
105.44
and he got some damage right there
escobar to his left
and it looks like paulo's done after
five and a third smiles and pats on the
back
well done
34 years young paulo espino
that is a high one hopper over to keep
him and over to bell he goes obviously
you're gonna see more of yadiel
hernandez but this guy can hit he can't
puts a charge into that one deep to
center and it's over the jump of ortega
keep him around third he will score
yeah he can hit and then answer on top
four to one
with a big pinch hit
and he hangs on that back leg forever
then he throws the hook strikes out
robinson charinos
that's it for him he'll go an inning and
a third and give up the base hit
and we certainly hope he's okay nets
need him for a while
you're swinging a smash that's going to
be a fair ball bouncing off the sidewall
down the left field line extra bass
knock ortega racing to the third going
to second safely as contrast with a
double yeah there are two outs in the
inning cubs could use a long ball from
patrick wisdom right now
and he hits a ground ball into left
field base hit one run is in john ferris
will head to third he's going to try to
score the throw of the plate not in time
to run single patrick wisdom 4-3 the
cubs trail they're right back in this
game in the eighth inning
[Applause]
like that
escobar turns it
four six three so now sergio alcanoa the
switch hitting shortstop pitch on the
way swinging a line drives caught by
garcia in the air sprawling to his left
on the edge of the outfield grass
and a curly w is in the box